hey everyone welcome to simply loans
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about slicers in excel but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech gig in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's get started with our
one point agenda that is slicers in
excel
so slices in excel are software filters
used along with excel tables or excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen
now microsoft excel slices are
compatible with windows and macintosh
operating systems now let us understand
how to implement slicers in excel so for
that we might want to get back to the
practical mode that is starting our
microsoft excel
now we are on our excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table
this table from microsoft excel is been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement the slices in excel we might
want to create or
convert the format of database into a
normal table for that you can select all
your data and just press ctrl t
and that will allow you an option called
convert the data into table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that
select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee id
employee name zone designation
department salary employees date of
birth and employee state of joining so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices
now let me select the first one that is
zone next designation department and
let's also select employee name
now press ok
and there you go we have our slicers
now let us try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done
now let us imagine that we want to see
or take a look at the employees who are
working in the east zone then we have
all the information displayed on the
screen who are working in the east zone
they are jack tony banner fred etc and
their department designation etc etc all
on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation
now for a change let's try to select the
department
now if your client wants to select the
data from only analytics department then
you might want to select on the
analytics key on the department slicer
and there you go you have an employee
called luke hopps who works in the east
zone and his department is analytics and
his designation is contract based
and the salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and
your client also wants data from id
support now you can see that analytics
is gone
but what if you want both analytics and
id support then you have an option
called select multiple
then you can select analytics and it is
supported if you want hr you can also do
that and in the zone if you want west
along with east then you can do the same
east and west and you have all the
employee details
and in the designation let's try to
select
senior trainee okay select multiple
senior trainee and manager so that's how
you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on slicers in excel
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you need the data set we used in this
particular tutorial then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here